Beer Lab.
Beer Lab, okay.
Are you bored of mass-produced beers?
The same old brands and the same dull flavors.
Imagine serving to your friends a unique tasting beer...
...that was invented and brewed by you at Beer Lab.
Beer Lab is a microbrewery, a bar and a bistro in Shanghai.
Beer Lab offers its customers two distinct values.
The first, the opportunity to make your own personal beer.
Second, a venue where fresh food and good food is served.
Beer Lab targets young professionals in China for three reasons.
Their growing number, their rapidly increasing disposable income...
...and their desire for more unique experiences.
We seek 40,000 US dollars to create the first Beer Lab in China.
We expect an IRR of 33 percent.
We have plans for rapid growth into the rest of China and in Asia.
Invest in Beer Lab, where the beer flows and the profits grow.